before we go any further I need to jump
in here Catherines already said that the
refresh button is for debugging only but
let's look at why in real life you
should always seek to eliminate the
refresh button from your app a good app
should work like a good Butler giving
you what you want before you even have
to ask for it much like the save button
it's a relic of a bygone age that's at
best a reassuring safety blanket for
those of us who grew up with floppy
disks with the ability to run background
tasks or send messages directly from the
server to our app there's really no
reason to force users to manually hit
refresh that the app is up to date and
synched with the cloud should be a given
but like we said this is for debugging
so like print line it's acceptable for
this particular purpose let's also take
a look at our background threading model
which of the following is potentially an
issue